la réponse que tendrait façon brève
c'est que ça dépend qu'est ce qu'on veut
dire par le mot science parce que à
plusieurs égards
la science ne s'est pas vraiment trompé
donc par exemple quand on garde
plusieurs années par plusieurs décennies
de recherche en communication politique
et en sciences politiques de façon plus
générale ce qu'on découvre c'est que
vous avez eu plusieurs chercheurs qui
ont démontré que la quantité d'attention
médiatique dont bénéficie un candidat
tendait à avoir une certaine corrélation
avec les résultats électoraux de ce
candidat là est ce qu'on a vu
particulièrement au niveau évidemment
des primaires républicaines aux
etats-unis six branches on part reçu une
quantité qu'on le mette disproportionnée
l'attention médiatique et ça semble très
clairement lui avoir quoi bénéficier
donc encore une fois si on résume ça est
ce que la science s'est trompé retraite
à certains égards mais prétendre
protector certains seront plus une
question qui est vraiment fascinant